[Music]
but i'm keeping this
thank you
[Music]
hey
um
hmm
alive
wow
oh
okay
five minutes
okay
finally
uh
or 10 minutes
are they going to say
yes
[Music]
um
um
no i don't think
is
yes
they did it for me to charge
is
[Music]
um
okay
oh
ah
is
i have a couple of items for all of you
at the top
uh first we welcome the unanimous
adoption today in the
u.n security council to extend the
mandate for a critical humanitarian ad
lifeline to syria
this agreement which will directly
impact the lives of millions of syrians
was the result of hard work among the
members of the council and intensive
diplomacy
following a detailed discussion at the
geneva summit between president biden
and president putin
today's resolution which renews the
cross-border agreement
that would have expired on july 10 will
provide further
life-saving humanitarian assistance the
people of northwest syria
and as part of a broader humanitarian
initiative led by the united nations
the two leaders today on their call
there was a readout that just went out
that should be in your inboxes you may
have seen
uh commended the work of their
respective teams following the summit
and welcomed the unanimous vote
in the council uh there was a readout i
should note that just went out of a call
the
president biden did with president putin
this morning i'm sure we'll talk more
about that
but just to note for all of your inboxes
um also today the president will sign an
executive order that will direct a
historic
whole government effort to promote
competition in the american economy
this effort has three goals lower prices
for consumers
higher wages for workers and more
innovation and economic
growth lack of competition drives up
prices for consumers
barriers to competition also drive down
wages for workers
when there are only a few employers in
town workers have less opportunity to
bargain for a higher wage
and to demand dignity and respect in
total higher prices and lower wages
caused by lack of competition
are now estimated to cost the median
american household
five thousand dollars per year so we
want to work to
address that competition is the engine
of our economy
uh and this is just the beginning we'll
be back in the weeks ahead to update you
on the progress we're making on this
executive order
and the concrete benefits we are
delivering to the american
people i also wanted to provide
a quick update for you on our work in
haiti
the united states remains engaged and in
close consultations with our haitian and
international partners to support
the haitian people in the aftermath of
the assassination
of the president in response to the
haitian government's request for
security and investigative assistance
we will be sending senior fbi and dhs
officials to port-au-prince
as soon as possible to assess the
situation and how we may be able
to assist i also wanted to note that in
january 2021
we announced a 75.5 million dollars for
a wide range of issues including
democratic governance health education
agricultural development
and strengthening of pre-election
activities strengthening
haiti's law enforcement capacity as a
key us priority
was before the assassination a few days
ago continues to be
and the u.s department of state's bureau
of international narcotics and law
enforcement affairs
provides assistance directly to the
haitian national police
we are also providing five million
dollars to strengthen the haitian
national police capacity to work with
communities to resist
gangs i also wanted to remind you all
that
earlier this year the department of
homeland security redesignated temporary
protected status for haiti
for 18 months something the secretary
announced
in may and something we are working to
implement
and finally haiti is one of the
countries that is
will be receiving vaccines from the
united states
we will be prepared to deliver those
hopefully as early as next week
part of that is assessing what the
airport
what can happen with the airport and how
we will be able to deliver
these um sorry one other two other
updates one other update and
and the week ahead uh on global vaccines
uh today we're sending three million
doses to indonesia
1.5 million doses to nepal 500 000 doses
to
moldova and 500 000 doses to bhutan
with these shipments in this week alone
we have sent nearly 15 million
doses to countries including guatemala
uruguay paraguay
bolivia afghanistan and vietnam on
indonesia i also wanted to add that in
addition to the vaccines we're also
sending
we're moving forward on plans to
increase assistance for indonesia's
broader coveted 19 response efforts
we recognize the difficult situation
indonesia currently finds itself in
with a surge of cove cases and our
thoughts are with those in indonesia who
are
affected finally let me get to the week
ahead on monday
the president will meet with local
leaders including law enforcement
elected officials and a community
violence inter intervention advocate
to discuss his administration's
comprehensive strategy
to reduce gun crimes and other violent
crimes
and that's here at the white house on
tuesday uh the president will deliver
remarks in philadelphia the birthplace
of democracy
on his administration's actions to
protect the sacred constitutional right
to vote
and the need to overcome anti-voter laws
he will make the moral case to the
american people on why the right to vote
is fundamental to who we
are as a nation on thursday the
president will deliver our marks to mark
the day
that tens of millions of families will
get their first monthly tax relief
payments
thanks to the american rescue plan the
expanded child tax credit provides
working families 250
each month for every child 6 to 17 years
old
and 300 each month for every child under
6 years old
also thursday the president will welcome
german chancellor angela merkel
to the white house for an official
working visit her visit will affirm the
deep and enduring bilateral ties
between the united states and germany
this forward-looking visit will address
our robust partnership on shared global
challenges and identify areas to
further strengthen cooperation in the
months and years ahead
and on friday the president will
participate in the asia pacific economic
cooperation leaders retreat
uh remotely obviously on the response to
the covet 19
pandemic on friday afternoon the
president will travel to camp david
where he will remain
over the weekend alex that was a lot of
information hopefully
go ahead and we have new information
about a call with president putin uh can
you tell us more about
what prompted this was it decided in
response
ransomware attacks um what exactly
did president biden say he reiterated
that the united states will take any
unnecessary action to defend its people
but spreads it that is and then um
i wanted to know uh the top of the
readout suggests that
it was partly sort of a pleasant call
the leaders commended their joint work
so can you explain why president biden
was
at all pleasant in this call when it
seems that there are
all of these grants and rare attacks
coming from russia that
may have been government approved uh
first uh let me say that uh the
president
is a believer in uh face-to-face
diplomacy when possible and leader to
the leader of diplomacy
when that's not possible and this is an
example of that and
uh this is the first time even though
ransomware attacks have been increasing
over the past
uh 18 months if not longer that there
has been this level of engagement
at this level and certainly the
president knew even when they met
in geneva that there would be a need for
ongoing discussions
and engagements i would say the reason
that they
commended the work of their teams is
this is consistent with the president's
view that diplomacy includes
working together where there is
opportunity in agreement and
being clear and candid and forthright
when there is disagreement and this call
is an example of that
so because of their agreement and the
discussion they had in geneva
the u.n security council is going to
extend access for humanitarian corridors
providing assistance humanitarian
assistance to people in syria people
that's something that is pivotal
and that is going to save lives that is
something to be commended
at the same time uh the president made
clearas i think you could see uh
in the readout uh that um
he underscored the need uh for president
putin to take action to disrupt these
ransomware groups
uh well uh our evil we know operates in
russia
and other countries around the world and
we don't have
additional or new information suggesting
the russian government directed
these attacks we also know and we also
believe
that they have a responsibility their
responsibility to take action
and as you can see in the readout the
president also made clear
that the united states will take any
necessary action to defend its people
and its critical infrastructure so
this was an example of uh leader to
leader diplomacy something the president
feels is vital
as he operates in the world on many cdc
guidelines i'm sure because there seems
to be a lot of confusion when these come
out
schools are now supposed to allow
teachers and students that are
vaccinated
not to wear masks but they're not
recommended to keep track of that
is that a recommendation enforceable and
if not why
even make the recommendation to begin
with and then going forward as we're
seeing
uh an increase in vaccinations and or
increasing
delta the delta variant in some of these
under vaccinated clusters
uh is there a situation in which the
administration would suggest
returning to virtual learning at all uh
first
the cdc laid out ways several months ago
that all schools can safely return to
in-person
learning that applies to schools in
areas where there are high levels of
vaccination
and areas where there are lower levels
of vaccination
and thanks to the american rescue plan
122 billion dollars in funding
schools can implement these mitigation
measures that they may not have been
able to
prior so this uh this guidance today
reiterated that mass should be worn
indoors by all unvaccinated individuals
schools should continue to maintain
at least three feet of physical distance
screening testing
ventilation hand washing and respiratory
etiquette staying home when sick and
getting tested
contact tracing with quarantine and
isolation and cleaning and disinfection
continue to be
important layers of prevention to keep
schools safe
now the guidelines that they provided
the guidance is in line with their
public health guidance that they have
provided broadly so if somebody is
vaccinated
they are safe if they are not vaccinated
which obviously applies to
uh children who are under a certain age
who are not yet eligible
then there are addition there are
guidelines that remain in place
how these guidelines will be implemented
has always been the purview of local
school districts
that has always been the case with
vaccines in general even prior to the
coronavirus so
this is public health guidelines that
they are providing it is up to the
school districts to
apply and implement go ahead jeff
some three weeks or so ago a president
biden in geneva
said that vladimir putin knows there are
consequences he knows i will take action
did he raise the volume of a similar
message in their call today
or did he amplify it in any way or did
he just repeat it
well i think as the readout makes clear
he reiterated
that the united states will take any
necessary action
to defend its people and its critical
infrastructure and he also reiterated
his expectation that president putin
take action
even if it is not directed by the
russian government and if it is
because of criminal actors in his own
country so
i'm not going to give you a a a tone and
tenor uh readout here but the president
believes that
uh this is that he's always believed
this was going to need to be
an ongoing diplomatic engagement with
the russians we've had expert level
talks
we've had uh those talks focused on
cyber focused on ransomware but he also
understands that there's going to need
to be talks at times at the leader level
i don't have any new information that
russia was involved in specifically
these tests is that right
correct are the cyber groups still
meeting next week the u.s group and the
russia side meeting next week go ahead
so in this call with president putin did
putin provide any assurances to
president biden that he will in fact
crack down on cyber criminals
that are in his country well i'm not
going to read out on behalf of the
kremlin i i will let them read out their
own uh what the president conveyed to
president
all right but did president putin
provide any assurances to president
biden on that call
again that's not an appropriate role for
the united states to convey uh i can
convey and read out to you what role
president biden played and what message
he delivered to the russians
go ahead so you've talked about the
visit of chancellor
mackel uh coming on thursday uh what to
what extent will president biden
ask germany and other countries
that are involved to stand with him in a
response to
russia on these ransomware attacks is
that a big part of your agenda
well uh i would say that it has long
been and it was back to
the g7 and the meetings on the
president's first foreign trip
part of his message to other european
leaders and partners was we need to
stand together and work together
to address the threat of ransomware
cyber attacks it is not just an issue
for the united states it is an issue for
a range of countries
uh around the globe in terms of what
percentage of the meeting i think we'll
have more as we get closer to the
meeting with
uh with uh chancellor merkel uh but
certainly i would expect
uh that uh the rising threat of cyber
and
ransomware would be part of the agenda
one more in germany and then another
quick one um so on germany
you know this one residual issue that is
still
to be addressed has to do with nordstrom
um to what extent
are you hopeful that you might be able
to reach some kind of an agreement or
extract some kind of promises from
germany
that would stave off the need to have
this
uh tariff as sanctions takes place
uh it certainly will be part of the
discussion uh and uh the president's our
view continues to be that it's a bad
deal and one
uh that has uh global uh issues uh
involved in it um but i i'm not going to
predict for you what the outcome of the
meeting will look like yeah
real quick on haiti yeah so we have some
reporting that there's investigation
going on
about the role that haitian americans
may have played in that attack can you
say a few words about your
understanding of that i understand
you're sending the fbi and dhs
and it may be a bit premature but any
readout now
i don't have anything to update in that
regard obviously the investigation is
being led
uh by uh haitian police forces on the
grounds there have been some reports i
think you're referencing
uh but i don't have any update beyond
that would that be a serious concern for
the white house if you
found that there were in fact american
citizens involved in this assassination
well certainly but i'm not going to get
ahead of where the investigation is
going it's ongoing it's led by the
haitians on the ground
uh go ahead kelly did the president in
his conversation with president putin
expand on the list that he presented to
him in geneva about the types of uh
critical infrastructure and parts of the
u.s economy that we're off limits
has the increase in ransomware informed
his view on that to expand that
and should we interpret this call and
the implicit warning in there again
as a sign that the u.s will act and act
soon
well first i would say that as as you
noted the president did provide a list
of critical infrastructure
when he met with president putin just a
few weeks ago he did that because
of course an attack on critical
infrastructure that would take out a
swath of the american
economy would have a significant
national security impact
uh he did not provide that list to say
if the attack is not on critical
infrastructure we're not going to take
action that was not the
restriction he gave himself and i think
in this uh
call today he was making clear that
again reiterating again
that attacks by criminal groups by
actors that
may not be directed by the russian
government you still have a
responsibility
and in terms of actions he made clear
that he is going to take steps
to defend uh the american people and our
own
uh infrastructure and our interests here
in the united states so while we're not
going to preview operationally what that
looks like
or what he may decide to do uh he did
make clear that he reserves that option
to take action and do you think the
president's intent in
having this call and on this topic
within the call was to send that signal
that
action could be imminent i think his
intent was to make clear
and reiterate again that attacks by
criminal groups
ransomware attacks by criminal groups uh
on uh
entities in the united states is not
acceptable uh and that we reserve the
right to take action
go ahead michelle thank you um did
president biden
specifically asked about casia and the
rnc hack
in this phone call and they couldn't say
he was investigating did he deny it
what was that conversation well i'm
still not going to read out what
president putin said
and i'm sure that the kremlin will do
their own readout of what he conveyed
i can tell you broadly that of course
the ransomware attack
that happened over the course of last
weekend was a
big focus of course of the call which
was uh was clear in the readout that we
provided
again i would reiterate on the rnc
attack that that
uh that the information we have to date
is that that was on a third party entity
and it's something the fbi is working
with them on we don't have additional
information beyond that at this point in
time
did the president express when he would
take this action
i'm just not going to have more to read
out for you on operational details or
specifics
artwork did the white house play any
role in crafting the sales
agreement with the new york gallery to
protect the purchasers or the ultimate
purchaser's identity
well i can tell you that after careful
consideration a system
has been established that allows for
hunter biden to work in his profession
within reasonable safeguards of course
he has
the right to pursue an artistic career
just like any child
of a president has the right to pursue a
career but all interactions regarding
the selling of art and the setting of
crisis
will be handled by a professional
gallerist adhering to the highest
industry standards
and any offer out of the normal course
would be rejected out of hand and the
gallerist will not
share information about buyers or
prospective buyers including
their identities with hunter biden or
the administration which provides
quite a level of protection now our
owner
and
a private citizen who might not be privy
to who might have some
interests in purchasing this artwork
is the white house doing anything to
work with the owner to make sure
um there's not impropriety there when it
is ultimately sold
well i think it would be challenging for
an anonymous person who
we don't know and hunter biden doesn't
know to have influence
so that's a protection go ahead thanks
jen um on this call this morning with
the russian president did
president biden discuss at all the
taliban delegation that was in moscow
yesterday
uh the the focus of the call and the
conversation which i can tell you was
about an hour long was really primarily
on these two topics i can see if there
was anything in addition
that was raised and i can follow up with
you after the briefing and then on the
um
afghan translators um does the the
president believe he has any
executive authority to determine where
these
afghan nationals await their views as i
know that the president said yesterday
you guys are working closely with
congress
you want to know what that looks like um
but in addition
does he have any influence on where they
wait out
this time period for their visas as he
similarly exercised with
immigrants in the southern border by
ending the remaining mexico policy
well it's a different program obviously
which i know you're conveying
and what we are trying to determine is
u.s facilities and bases that are
located
in different parts of the world where we
can house uh
these brave and courageous individuals
while their processing
continues uh so that's what we're
determining we have not made a final
determination of that
we're trying to also protect for
security and operational reasons
uh what that may look like even when a
final determination is made so
i would see it as a different type of a
program and but those are the
considerations and it's already law
so we are we are in a position where we
can uh make a decision to
uh to relocate individuals from
afghanistan to these third-party
countries
and then on the uh the vaccine pfizer
requesting uh approval for a third shot
from regulators
uh cdc fda said at this time you don't
need a booster
to be considered vaccinated but what
what's the timeline that
you guys are looking at on when that
would be recommended
uh especially as it pertains to meeting
vaccination requirements to
forego things like masks well first
and uh you referenced this but just for
for others uh the cdc and the fda put
out a pretty clear statement last night
after the announcement by pfizer
making clear that americans who have
been fully vaccinated do not need a
booster shot at this time
i'd also note that they are in
constantly engaged in a rigorous process
to consider
when a booster might be necessary but
it's i can't make a prediction of that
that's going to be led by the data and
by the science uh but at this time
that is not a determination that they
have made and we wanted to make
uh clear uh that uh that is not
something that the american people need
to plan for at this moment
i'm just gonna jump around because i i
haven't gotten to a bunch of people in
this room in a couple days
go ahead go ahead go ahead a couple in
afghanistan um just to follow
yesterday the president said that he
didn't he actually denied the
intelligence community had assessed that
after the afghan government
collapsed um that conflicts with their
reporting at the journal and other news
outlets that said that it lasts within
six months so is he not briefed on that
intelligence are you denying that
that intelligence exists at all first i
would say that we
uh of course abide by the intelligence
presented by our own intelligence
community
but the way the question was answered
and in part presented was whether it was
inevitable
and the president does not believe that
it is inevitable
uh the intelligence community has never
said it was inevitable
uh for the uh for the taliban to take
over
the country and so his objective or his
uh
uh what he was trying to convey was that
um there's a responsibility and the
responsibility now lies
in the hands of the afghans we have uh
provided we have trained over 300
thousand we've provided
3.9 billion dollars in humanitarian
assistance these are brave fighters who
have fought off
taken on casualties and fought off uh
over the course of the last several
years we want to
equip and empower them and it is now in
their hands but it is not inevitable
nor has any intelligence assessment
predicted it was inevitable
just one more yesterday he also said
that that the us doesn't bear
responsibility for any deaths that might
occur after the
after the u.s withdrawals can you
explain you know how the u.s
doesn't bear any responsibility for that
i think what the president was conveying
is that we are doing everything we can
to equip train and power the afghan
national security forces and we're going
to continue to remain engaged not just
through the end of august
but then forward but it is going to be
up to them
to uh to it is ultimately their job and
responsibility
now and to demonstrate their
capabilities and their will to defend
their country
and that was what he was working
attempting to convey yesterday
on the competition executive order was
there any discussion about
trying to accomplish those goals through
legislation and would that be the
president's preferred approach over an
executive order that could be overturned
by his
successor well there's certainly value
in legislation it makes it more
permanent though so there's no question
about that but
the president is going to continue to
use authorities that every president
before him has had
uh executive actions executive uh
which allow him to take actions to make
uh industries more competitive
to bring relief to consumers in the
american people so
i'm not going to rule out future
legislative discussions with congress
should they want to pursue them
but these are actions he could take that
could have a huge immediate impact on
the american people
uh go ahead in the middle um just two
quick questions jen the first is
i spoke with a number of justice
organizations and families that want to
know if the president is going to
address the over 4 000
inmates low offender inmates that are at
home sent home due to the pandemic that
they have to go back
they're saying that they want to know is
he going to make a statement how is he
going to address it
and is he willing to find a way to keep
them home whether that's
granting clemency or ordering a doj to
go back and revisit that memo that was
done under the trump administration
sure it's a great question it is
something the president is following
closely
a lot of it is under the purview of the
department of justice i can see if
there's any new update for you that i
can provide to you after the briefing
um on the campaign trail the president
said especially for those moments when
this campaign was at its lowest the
african-american community
stood up again for me then they always
have my back and i'll have
theirs with that said i know you said on
tuesday he's going to philly but there
are many activists on the ground who
feel like the president has not done all
that he can are we going to see him
going state to state like he did with
infrastructure and having a very
in-your-face approach
with many republicans like in arizona
confronting some of these rules or even
pressing democrats
when it comes to nuking the filibuster
well first i would say that the speech
the president is delivering is about
our fundamental right to vote in the
country and
the moral obligation we all have to
defend that stand up for that
it's not about legislative process and
this issue
is bigger than that um and i would say
that to
those who are critics we stand with you
and wanting to make voting more
accessible around the country
and that's why the president signs a
historic executive order
into law in his first month in office
that's why
he his department of justice has already
taken action to
double the funding and support around
the country to fighting
of voter laws and fighting voter
suppression that's why he fought
nominated and fought for the
confirmation of kristin clark and vinita
gupta two
civil rights activists who are now
playing prominent roles
in the department of justice he has said
this will be the cause of his presidency
he's delivering a speech in philadelphia
the foundation of democracy next tuesday
and that's a continuation of his efforts
go ahead jen thank you nobody really
would expect you to preview
what the united states might do as a
retaliatory cyber attack
on russia but does the president
understand that
assuming russia would not acknowledge
such an attack does he understand it for
political
consumption domestic political
consumption and perhaps worldwide
political consumption
that we have to make some kind of show
of it we have to point out that we have
to respond to the united states
has responded uh and then the president
has
fulfilled what he said it would do i
would say the president
doesn't make his global decisions or his
decisions as commander-in-chief or
a leader in the global community based
on politics he makes them on what is in
the interest of our
national security in the interest of the
american people and certainly i know you
alluded to this but i don't think anyone
expects
him or us to preview our punches he
reserves that option
has been clear about that and we're
probably not going to preview that
in advance go ahead karen i think i've
answered your question go ahead karen
thanks two questions on vaccines and
back to the pfizer uh
the third shot's better you mentioned
that the fda and the ccc came out very
quickly with the statement saying it's
not needed at this time but is anybody
in the administration
asking pfizer to coordinate on
announcements like this so americans
are not confused to see such a whiplash
of headlines
well they are private sector company i
can't speak to their uh
the origin or the motivation of their
announcement you'd have to ask them that
but
the role we can play from the us
government is to
provide accurate information and public
health information which is what we
ventured to do last night
pretty rapidly uh in response to the
announcement and you were asked about
this on wednesday
uh on air force one but i just want to
go back to it because there's still
pushback about the president's comments
about
going door to door to encourage
vaccinations the south carolina governor
said today that
enticing coercing intimidating mandating
or pressuring anyone to take a vaccine
is a bad policy
that will deteriorate the public trust
and confidence in the state's efforts
and
governor mcmaster said he's going to
prohibit the state health agency
from using the administration's targeted
tactics can you respond to the governor
and explain
what it is that is being done and what
is not being done
in this outreach sure well let me first
say that the failure to provide accurate
public health
information including the efficacy of
vaccines and the accessibility of them
to people across the country including
south carolina is literally killing
people
so maybe they should consider that but i
would say that what this
is and what is it is not this is not
federal employees going door-to-door
this is grassroots volunteers this is
members of the clergy
these are volunteers who believe that
people across the country especially in
low vaccinated areas
should have accurate information should
have information about where they can
get vaccinated
where they can save their own lives and
their neighbors lives and their family
members lives
that's exactly what this is it's
something that's been going on
since april and it's something where
we've seen an impact in states where
there are lower
vaccination rates so it is something we
will continue
to uh to work with local groups to do
and it's a disservice to the country and
to the people who
may lose their lives who may lose family
members to provide
inaccurate disinformation at a moment
where we're still fighting a pandemic go
ahead george
thanks uh two questions on the
president's trade agenda
uh he's spoken a lot about buy america
and
he settled the air bus i think but when
can we expect
activity on the major things like
lifting
the trump tariffs or the uk
talks sure um this is of course under
the
purview of ambassador tai uh and
somebody who is working
every day to work with countries around
the world to communicate what our agenda
is i don't have anything to predict for
you in terms of
additional components of his trade
agenda i will note that
as he looks at our global approach or
economic approach
uh he believes that we need to build the
middle class
make sure we are making decisions
through the prism of what's going to
help
the middle class here in the united
states yeah any reaction to the imf
calling on him to lift the tariffs we're
continuing to review i don't have any
update for you on a timeline
go ahead thank you so i have a question
on vaccine sharing in there on
afghanistan
on vaccine sharing um many humanitarian
organizations say that despite
one billion doses pledged by g7 the
lion's share which is coming from the us
it's still not nearly enough to get the
world vaccinated to stop the spread of
variance my question is
does the administration have any plans
to expand from the 580 million
doses already pledged and jumping up on
your indonesia announcement
the jakarta government has just
announced that they are going to use the
three million modern
doses to vaccinate one and a half
million
um healthcare workers who have already
been
vaccinated fully vaccinated with
cyanobatch so
um would you care to comment about that
in in
in regards to u.s vaccine diplomacy
versus chinese vaccinations
sure well first i would say that there
are no uh strings attached to our
vaccines that we're providing we're
providing them around the world to
save lives and to be a contributor to
the global effort to fight the pandemic
you're absolutely right that there are
more doses needed beyond the billion i
would note that
the united states is far and away the
largest contributor in the world to
the fight against the pandemic including
specific doses of vaccines
and we have the president has made clear
that that we will continue to build from
here and we're working on
manufacturing capacity around the world
and in the united states and we will
continue to contribute even beyond
the billion doses taliban has captured a
key
border crossing with iran today a move
that's designed to choke the kabul
government economically
so if the taliban continues to make
military gains
to push the kabul government towards
collapse at what point would the
president
reconsider his strike policy to include
airstrikes on the taliban rather than
just isis and al-qaeda
well i'm not going to predict an outcome
that we are certainly working to
with the afghan national security forces
to push against
i can reiterate of course why the
president made the decision he made
based on a clear-eyed assessment of what
the impact could be
but at this point in time what our focus
is on is ensuring we are
bringing our servicemen and women home
from afghanistan on the timeline he
outlined yesterday
that we are spreading our
counterterrorism capacity out to parts
of the world
where we see the biggest threats beyond
afghanistan that we are continuing to
work to empower equip
train support financially the afghan
national security forces go ahead
thank you jen um we're almost halfway
through the 90-day period
that the white house has set for the u.s
intelligence community to
redouble efforts and analyze information
about the origin of
19. um is the president receiving or has
the president received any update on
that
i don't have any updates to provide to
all of you but go ahead thank you
and then uh second question uh delegates
the national education association they
approved a measure last week calling for
support of quote
implementation of culturally responsive
education
critical race theory and ethnic studies
curriculum in pre-k through 12
and higher education president is
obviously a big fan of education
first lady is a teacher she's a union
teacher
i'm wondering what are the president's
thoughts on anti-racism curriculum
in the classroom well the president
believes that in our history
uh there are many dark moments and there
is not just
slavery and racism in our history there
are systemic racism
that is still impacting society today
and he believes as i believe as a parent
of children
that kids should learn about our history
uh so as a
the spouse of an educator and as
somebody who is continues to believe
that children should learn uh not just
the good but also the challenging in our
history and that's part of what we're
talking about here even as it's become
politically
charged thank you go ahead i just want
to follow up on something you said about
kaiser before we said this is a private
sector company
yeah this company that's gotten billions
of dollars from the federal government
and it's a key part of probably
the most important effort you're working
on right now given that is it still not
appropriate to coordinate on messaging
that might confuse people
well again the role we can play is to
determine how we communicate from the
federal government
uh and how we communicate accurate
public health information
to the american people and that's what
we ventured to do as quickly as possible
last night after the statement came out
um go ahead jen
um just on the eo that the president is
about to sign
um we've seen some of the business
groups that you know while not
often the allies of democrats have been
especially around the infrastructure
deal groups like the chamber of commerce
um expressing concern that government is
just kind of inserting itself too much
into business dealings national
association of manufacturers saying
um their solutions in search of a
problem um
threatening to undo progress by
undermining free markets that are
premised on
false notion or workers are not
positioned for success
um and you know and more broadly are you
just concerned about the the reaction
coming from industry that they will try
to push back on this that there will
likely be lawsuits and all and all kinds
of other things that could bog down this
and how are you uh planning to respond
to all that
there's there may be but i think the
role and the president's role
is uh to uh to focus on what's in the
interest of american consumers
and his view is that when you have a
lack of competition that's driving up
prices for consumers driving down wages
for
workers a lack of competition that is
costing the median american household
five thousand dollars per year
that as the president of the united
states somebody who represents middle
class americans across the country he
has a responsibility to act
we understand some may be opposed to
that uh ben
that's okay it's a free country uh go
ahead and jim
go ahead very quickly brian thank you uh
the follow-up to that is uh
you said in the statement today that
he's going to take decisive
action against consolidation in a lot of
industries
does that include media industry i mean
we suffer consolidation more than any
other
so is that is your administration going
to break up the large media
conglomerates i don't have anything to
predict or preview for you on that front
go ahead
and cover it okay
nothing crazy's happening the pool has
to gather go ahead
yeah how will the arrest of two
americans affect
the assistance that the fbi and dhs
provides to haitian apartments
our assistance is to help the people of
haiti
and to help them uh get through what is
a very challenging time and has long
been even before the assassination of
the president
uh so the investigation is not going to
impact the assistance we're providing
to the people of haiti but as you as i
announced at the beginning we are
sending because supporting uh law
enforcement efforts on the ground uh
and making sure we are providing
resources in terms of
women and manpower uh but also financial
resources is part of what our objective
is as well how many law enforcement
agents are we sending
and have there been any requests for any
additional aid from the us either from
the state department
or another agency well this uh this
action was in response to a specific
request so
that's what it exactly was i don't have
a specific number i can check and see if
there's something more specific we can
provide to you go ahead eugene
is the bank administration considering
easing travel restrictions to allow
vaccinated people into the u.s
um the cdc has already said that you can
it's safe to travel i've done it
if you're fully vaccinated there's an
ongoing
uh process which i know is to the
frustration of many uh
which includes working groups uh with
countries so that we can communicate
about
and share information about what the
criteria will be for easing these travel
restrictions
uh we certainly want to ensure families
are reunited
people are reunited people can travel as
you have as you said
but i don't have anything to predict in
terms of the timeline there the question
is if the conditions are
the same they're otherwise the same why
is the destination
matter they look at a range of criteria
but it's based on public health
uh discussions public health experts are
a part of these discussions on
on all sides from our country and from
the others who are participating
um in may the administration came out in
support of the trip's waiver
um which would make vaccines more
available around the world by waiving
the ip protections
angela merkel will be here um next
thursday germany is against the trips
waiver
they and i think has to be unanimous is
president biden is that on the agenda
for president i didn't talk to her about
that
he is a strong proponent of it it's one
tool in our toolbox there are a number
of others including
increasing manufacturing obviously we've
already made an announcement about
the number of doses 500 million we're
sharing around the world we've already
started implementing them
i know it sounds like there's a lot of
interest in what will be on the agenda
let me see if there's more about
the agenda for the meeting with the
german chancellor to uh predict
uh let me go all the way to the go ahead
in the middle in the middle thanks john
uh just two quick questions first on
voting rights
is the speech next week in pennsylvania
is it like a one-off speech or is the
president gonna
sort of consistently start to to deliver
speeches and have events publicly
on this issue well he just had a meeting
with civil rights leaders uh yesterday
uh
and we provided a readout of that uh so
i can't predict for you what the
schedule will look like beyond next
tuesday but this is an opportunity to go
to the birthplace of democracy to make
the case for the moral
imperative of making voting more
accessible to people across the country
it's been several months since uh uh
irritant was withdrawn as the nominees
lead
omb is there an update on the timeline
for when the president might
uh nominate a full-time nominee to lead
that department
there i do not have a timeline update
for you go ahead thanks jen
as you probably have noticed gas prices
are up considerably
right now all across the u.s the average
price of gasoline is
three dollars and fourteen cents in fact
gas prices are up forty percent
since the very beginning of the year uh
what is your message
to motorists out there in the country
that are concerned about how much it
costs
to get to work every day uh how it's
really impacting their family budgets
well first i would say that gas prices
do historically rise in the summer and
that's particularly true even in moments
like this where there's a spike in
people traveling
and even more people are hitting the
road now because of our success in
defeating the pandemic
so in the last 10 years pre-pandemic for
example the average price of gas in july
is nearly 30 cents higher than it is in
january
and any prices are higher now than they
were last year because americans are
finally able to travel
i just thought that context was
important as it relates but the
president
is quite focused on ensuring uh that we
are doing everything we can
to keep uh prices low uh for the air to
keep the cost of living low for the
american people including
the cost of gas that's why he was
against vehemently against
a gas attacks why he was against a
vehicle mileage tax
we are not a member a party of opec as
you know
we are engaged with a number of
countries in part because we want to
ensure that we are remaining abreast of
what is happening in those discussions
as well because that will have an impact
but his direct message to the american
people is that
uh he is going to uh work uh just as he
worked to get the virus under control
he's going to and to create jobs he's
going to work to ensure we are
doing everything we can to keep the gas
at price level
uh oil from the spr have any impact is
that
a consideration of the administration i
don't have anything to predict on that
front
sure go ahead extinction as
a candidate uh president biden said and
i'm quoting uh
quote i've never spoken to my son about
his overseas business dealings
but recently photographs and documents
have called that into question
uh in 2015 uh president biden as vice
president met at cafe milano
uh with the sons ukrainian russian and
kazakhstani business associates
one day before a brisbane executive
thanked the first son for the
opportunity to meet his father
and also in 2015 as vice president the
president hosted at the naval
observatory
mexican business associates under biden
before
uh hunter biden emailed these associates
from air force two the next year going
to mexico
so i've had a two-part question um was
president biden indeed unaware
that his son was pursuing business
opportunities for these people he met
and also according to recent reporting
the first son still has a
chinese investment company when is he
going to unload that
i on the last part he's working to
unload that i'd point you to his
representatives the president
does not discuss business dealings with
family members and otherwise i'm not
going to respond to rudy giuliani's
lawyer
um go ahead in the back go ahead go
ahead
thanks john i wanted to ask you about
the executive order
that the president is going to sign on
competition most of that executive order
to me looks like it would be done
through regulation that the agencies
yeah and he's directing a whole bunch of
different rule making
can you talk about so the office inside
omb
that handles regulation still has no
director or administrator i believe in
the title
can you talk about how the coordination
is going to go to get this all out the
door
and make sure that it's i mean across
the teens stop the eyes
without someone in that job that would
traditionally do that
sure well first i would say that omb has
is one of the agencies in the federal
government that is also staffed by
talented
men and women from the career service
and they can help make sure we are
continuing to function
and implement government actions and
that continues to be the case in this
regard
as you noted the order uh includes
several actions that agencies would take
which
those actions would be implemented
within agencies even independent
agencies of course will make
their own decisions so this order is
encouraging independent agencies to take
certain
certain actions even as they make those
decisions but
the federal government is designed in a
way so that we can function from
administration to administration
even as individuals need to be nominated
and confirmed and that is certainly the
case in this
uh regard as well um all right let's see
go ahead go ahead go ahead
so since tempo won the stanley cup what
is president obama all right
i wasn't on my bingo card today but
that's fine
um what is president biden receiving
from prime minister trudeau because i
know that there's a
bet out there and then when are you
going to see the lightning or other sort
of
bigger events start happening again at
the lighthouse soon we've already
started to have events as you all know
we've had some over the course of the
last few weeks we've already welcomed
one sports team
here to the white house and there will
be more to come i don't have a
prediction of the timeline but
uh we are starting to schedule and plan
those events for the coming months
like what is what is the president
getting from the prime minister
i don't have an update on that
specifically uh but we can see if
there's more detail to share why don't
we go all the way in the back
thanks plan uh can you give us an update
on the nuclear calls to vienna
will we have a seventh round of talks
sorry i didn't hear the last part yes
uh that is certainly uh the intention
but i don't have any
update on the timeline of those uh go
ahead next to you thank you very much
um on china is white house planning to
hold another phone call with a chinese
leadership
and on at the g20 summit in october is
president biden willing to hold a summit
with she
on the sidelines uh i know that g20 com
summit is coming up right around
halloween uh but that is quite some time
from now
in terms of the planning and what other
events may or may not be around it
uh certainly we are in touch at a very
high level with chinese leaders
in terms of an upcoming call with
president xi i don't have anything to
predict on that front
uh why don't we go all the way i'm just
trying to get all the way to the back
because i'm
not great at doing that go all the way
in the vr go ahead go ahead
thank you jen um on the competition
policy executive order are are there
any uh additional steps that have
already been taken
like at the interagency level so that
we're going to see a proposed rule from
the department of transportation on
airline fees or something last tuesday
how much of this is sort of pre-staged
versus
starting at the beginning of the process
well where
we're appropriate with agencies that are
of course not independent agencies that
we've been working closely with we have
been working with them to develop
policies and do that in alignment
the timing of proposed rules i would
point you to each agency obviously as
you know that takes
some time depending on the complication
of the rule but
uh we we developed this through an
interagency process
where where appropriate uh and there is
of course broad support for
the competition agenda in the
administration
um because there was another the
bipartisan policy center had a report
the other day on the debt limit
treasury has been unclear on when
exactly the x date will arrive uh is the
president going to be pushing
congress to raise the debt limit or
suspend it again
uh before they leave for the august
recess
uh in the early august i think the
president certainly expects that
congress will
take steps as they have uh three times
during the prior administration
to uh raise the debt limit all right i
think we have to wrap up because i think
you have to
we're going to move to the president's
remarks uh thank you everyone have a
wonderful weekend